i feel like society today especially
millennials we're addicted
to feeling sensitive and offended like
literally people's nipples get hard
when they're freaking offended by
something with the election upon us
millions of americans are gearing up to
cast their vote for the next president
of the united states
while some people will be voting
independent we wanted to hear from trump
voters and biden voters about why they
are voting for their candidate
in spectrum we bring everyday people
together for authentic discussions that
represent what's happening now
these discussions should not be anyone's
sole source forming opinions on
important issues
please do your own research seek out
experts
push yourself outside your bubble and
have empathy thanks for watching
hello my name's rachel i'm from dallas
texas
i've been a conservative my whole life
but my views have definitely evolved and
i'm happy to be here
hi i'm casey i live in pittsburgh
pennsylvania and i actually work in
politics and have watched very closely
kind of the republican party turn from
republicanism to kind of trump
republicanism and i'm excited to talk
about that
hi my name is noah i'm a teenage
conservative from the great state of
georgia
i've been a conservative for my whole
life and i'm really looking forward to
this discussion
my name is malik i'm from detroit
michigan i just turned 23 i was always
economical even when i was very little
now i'm a medical student
in the state of georgia hi my name is
amy when it comes to social issues and
everything i
could be considered a little bit more
liberal but i do support our president
100 percent four more years was good
hi my name is alicia i'm 20 years old my
mom
immigrated to america from nicaragua as
a political refugee
and then my father's side of the family
immigrated from mexico
and i am also eight months pregnant and
i'm super excited to be a first time mom
trump's behavior can be offensive
rachel somewhat disagree casey
agree noah agree
ami alicia
strongly agree agree
i think that trump gets a lot of flack
more than other presidents
for offending people because he is not
politically correct
the politically correct culture has been
shoved down our throats
and the reason why people like his
rhetoric is because he doesn't put up
with that toxic culture
the reason i said agree is because wally
hasn't directly offended me
i do think some of the some of his
writer can be offensive i mean i i'm
sure stormy daniels was pretty offended
to be called
horse face even though it was epic when
it comes to a lot of his policies i tend
to agree with him uh what he what he's
done with the taxes i think we can all
agree on
if we could just take his twitter
account away sometimes and just limit
what he says or get
a good writer in there for his tweets i
think we'd be in a way better place in
the country
i actually enjoy president trump's
tweets i have notifications
yeah i agree with him yeah and i don't
even factor in the rhetoric
but when it comes to president trump
anymore because of
all the results that he's gotten and if
that's how he has to behave in order to
uh achieve the results i'm totally fine
for it i see a fighter
and that's what i like about him the one
time he offended me
i quickly found out that it was from
fake news so that was in the beginning
of the election when he was running in
2016.
um it was a disabled thing like a little
that little thing
that offended me but that quickly
dissipated when i found out that's what
he does
everything else that i have heard him
say from this point
um i haven't felt personally offended
but when i hear him say certain things
i'm like i could hear the screeching i
could hear
you just hear like the freaking people
freaking out yeah and one thing that i
say
kind of offended me that i kind of
didn't like was
when he the hollywood access tape
grabbed him by the you know
i didn't really like that but then um as
i thought about it more
i thought he wasn't running for
president he was a democrat at the time
uh and this has nothing to do with who
he is today he was talking about
groupies
yeah and he and to me like when i
actually looked at the context and
everything like
yeah now no i know who he's talking
about he's not talking about oh
i mean i could just grab no you can't do
that to honor me
to do that i'm gonna hit you with a
backhand over there
exactly like he's talking about the
women that are like not just any woman
particular and think of when he said
that stuff too and access hollywood
by that time donald trump was being
talked about in rap videos he was on
comedy central during those roles he was
in
hollywood we know who he was talking
about so when all these people
especially in the black community
would you dare use the graphing by if
if he had been black and said it in the
rap song
oh wait wait wait he's a republican oh
no no we disagreed we disagree
i was only ever offended by trump once
and this was whenever
he said something about like mexicans
being like animals or like something
like that
and so i was like oh my gosh it's so
offensive like why would he say that
and then i said i was like did you read
like everything that he said
so i went back and he was talking about
like the ms-13 gangs that were in mexico
and stuff
so i like kind of learned a lot about
fake news
and how a lot of people are like
sensitive
to his like rhetoric and what he says
what do you think
i feel like society today especially
millennials we're addicted
to feeling sensitive and offended like
literally people's nipples get hard
when they're freaking offended by
something mommy i mean i think i know
why that is
it's because if i'm offended if i'm a
victim i get more attention it's like
there's a hierarchy of victimhood
well i'm black but you're black on me
and a woman so that means you get more
power it's like
in the left it's like the more
victimized you are
the more you should be heard the more
power you should be given and to me i
think that's pretty sad
systemic racism is a problem in america
strongly disagree ac somewhat disagree
noah i said some would agree amy
someone agree alicia
i said strongly disagree somewhat
agree systemic implies that
it's built into the dna of a country
and i just don't think that that was why
this country was founded
it wasn't founded to be a racist country
systemic is
really that there's laws in place
that prevent people of color from
excelling and while in the past there
definitely have been laws
that were systemically racist there
aren't any
anymore there's so many examples people
of color
that excel in america for example like
barack obama he's like
a black president you also have like aoc
who was a bartender
she's a person of color and she
literally just like came
up and became like you know house of
representative can i ask everybody this
real quick
joe biden's 94 crime bill that
specifically targeted people of
color you wouldn't consider that to be
systematic something that was put into
place that is going to target
the breakdown won the breakdown of the
black family sorry to be like uh
military but there's some skid marks
america has some like total skid marks
yeah there has been like is like i'm
studying history and i'm taking old
south class so we're just talking about
slavery like so i'm not denying that
there hasn't been systemic slavery
before
but in 2020 today like there's not
systemic racism but just in the 90s 94
that was the year i was born
there's no not too long ago and the
residue the effects that it had within
two generations
um is you know it looks pretty
structured to me you know what i mean i
mean i i really like what you have to
say with um the 1994 crime bill because
that's exactly where i was going with it
that's why
some would agree and other policy that i
think is also really important
would be school choice in the schools
that where i was growing up
with the way they teach history and the
way they teach the spirit
you know that they were spirit bro i
felt like
in the classroom you are determined that
you will fail
you cannot succeed you will never make
it and to me
personally whenever somebody told me i
can't do something i said okay
watch and then i went to medical school
but uh for
a lot of other people they don't have
what i have you know so
i think it is systematic because it's
mostly black people in these areas being
taught these things
that keep them from even thinking that
it's possible for them to achieve
so that's why i say systematic racism is
a problem and it comes from the
democratic side
i have to disagree there's no law saying
that you have to teach black
children that they can't make it in the
world the issue is really funding
and i think people get distracted and
tend to blame it on system
on systemic racism when it's not it's
really a poverty issue
you don't think that systematically
white kids are in poor districts as well
and there are
tons of districts around the nation who
that are a majority white
and they're poor but black people are
typically if we look at statistics black
people are in that lower
income people of color are in that lower
income
bubble right there i feel like that's
systematic you know what i mean it's
targeting a specific group but there are
tons of white kids in that bubble too
no i i didn't i didn't yeah i i didn't
dis i didn't uh
disagree on that part i definitely gave
a shout out to you know there are white
kids in the trailer park
i think a lot of it has to do with like
the
culture or the way that the like like
normal typical black families set up
the statistics say that uh black people
don't have like two family households
and that has a lot to do yeah that has
like a lot to do with like oh
the poverty rates their like where they
end up in school and they go to jail
more often so i don't think it's
systemic
racism and like more is that it's a fact
of
having to like educate we've done a lot
to deal with race in this country
applaud my friends on the left they
literally just see
that it is a racist country we're never
not going to be and we need
like insane change to
just blow up the system i think that
that that would be the most
foolish thing when you look at who's
helping the black community
uh i think that president trump has done
a ton for the black opinion
more than under any more than under
barack obama that's for sure
i believe covet 19 is a serious and
real disease
rachel disagree casey
i strongly agree noah i somewhat agree
amy alicia
doesn't somewhat agree malik
some would agree any anything that can
cause the death of somebody is serious i
can strongly agree with that statement
while at the same time
being against a lot of the measures that
have been taking place especially over
an extended period of time
it's affected my mental health and i
have a lot of people who are scared to
kind of speak out but of course
the disease itself yes it's real yes
it's serious it's very serious i've
known people who have family members who
have passed away
but what if i don't believe it's to the
degree that the media made it out to be
i mean they said really early on two
million people will die and we're at 200
000.
overall it's most likely been inflated a
lot and this is a really interesting
question for me because i'm in medical
school i have access to information that
like the general public doesn't
so the thing i would say is context is
not being given to the general public
i noticed one a week there was like oh
my god there's been a surge in this
state
well i know a drive-through uh just
opened was there really a surge
in cases or was there a surge in testing
i think that
we are being distracted by the real
problem in america
and the real problem in america is that
we're not healthy overall
we're one of the sickest countries who's
a first world country
so i think the media has really blown it
out of proportion um
i don't think it's as serious as it's
made out to be it's being politicized to
scare people
um and i don't know if you guys remember
in the very beginning when they talked
about this kovit they said that
the african-american community was
actually
uh you know more prone to getting kovid
or the chinese virus gotta say it guys
gotta say chinese virus
and it makes sense if we wanna look at
the black community specifically when it
comes to high blood pressure heart
disease diabetes we got to take that in
consideration and unfortunately we can't
really compare ourselves to sweden
you can't really compare ourselves to
these other countries the one have this
much smaller population
and also live healthier lifestyles than
we do as americans
i am open to liberal ideas
rachel agree and you casey
agree noah i strongly agree
mommy strongly agree elysia
i said agree
agree so i said agree
like right now they're just like
portraying
so many radical views that it's like
shutting
me down from like listening to them
entirely
like socialism that's like the number
one for me because i know that socialism
leads to communism and people cannot
tell me otherwise
and like my family actually like left
nicaragua because of like the socialist
like stuff and the communism that was
happening so
and i know a lot of hispanic people like
that's probably why joe biden isn't
getting like
any but that much support he is getting
support but not that much support i am
super conservative but i'm also an
urbanist and i don't mind uh i live in a
city
i'm totally open to it and even apply
some i mean i'm i'm almost vegan so i
had to say that because i'm almost but
you know it's okay for conservatives to
care about the environment and things
like that
something that you would consider
liberal i especially liked listening to
andrew yang
it's hard to hate that guy and you just
can't um but i
i nothing about joe biden interests me
my biggest voting issue of all is china
and i think that it is
the chinese communist party is the
biggest threat to the global order but
especially the american way
and joe biden has made it very clear
that he's he's really not going to do
too much to
handle them and in the past has actually
enabled them i'm very very open
to having discussions with literally
everybody um
i'm in blexit and down here in our
tennessee chapter
when we are come across black lives
matter we cross over the street and we
talk
to them friendly peacefully great
conversation we find a ton of middle
ground we had each other on freaking
facebook
but i feel like leftists today should
just be open and honest and just call
themselves marxists because there's
literally no pretty much no difference
now these days when it looks at when you
look at bernie sanders when you look at
black lives matter and then let's add in
a bunch of like illegal immigrants
when we can't even take in our own take
care of our own people
there's no logic there's no logic to it
i'm open
to talking and adopting things like who
you decide to marry and all that kind of
stuff
i'm open to that give people equal
opportunity
to succeed but if you want to look at
the lgbtq stuff
i'm done for you as an adult talking to
another
adult and consenting to do whatever you
do but i'm not
for is shoving it down children's
throats i'm a mom of three
i don't play that no what do you need to
talk about to my kids
about your um dangling stuff and what
you decided we don't care they want to
play with your toys
yeah i actually uh oh i i work for the
gay republican group
uh so i am uh their poli
political director in pennsylvania and
ohio and i as far as
as far as gay issues go i i think that
people looking to pass
gay marriage or like repeal gamer i
think that's big government
i think the government shouldn't decide
what is defined as marriage
at all donald trump has stood for the
gays in gay marriage what
winning for a lot longer than joe biden
has joe biden and
entered the 2012 presidential campaign
still opposing gay marriage and so if
we're going to talk about that issue
then i
i feel like public opinion has come
around on that i said i strongly agree
because the high school i graduated from
i was able to graduate with a kid who
i believe he worked on bernie sanders
campaign at some point and i've been
able to talk to them frequently since
we've graduated we've had a lot of
discussions
we have to understand there's not
liberal problems and conservative
problems there's
american problems that we all have we
just have two we all have the same end
goal we just have two different ways to
get there we all want america to be
better at least i hope we do
i try to i try to say what if i'm wrong
and what if they're right so i can
truly see what they think america is
better now than it was
four years ago
rachel strongly agree
casey i strongly agree noah
i strongly agree ami
somewhat agree
i said strongly agree malik
strongly agree yeah so i put i
somewhat agree and i kind of actually
sucks to say because i wish it was
strongly agree
but when in terms of race relations um i
feel like we've taken so many steps
backwards i never thought
that as a millennial and somebody in
2020 that i would go outside my door
and there would be like tension friends
disowning each other family disowning
each other i know i'm experiencing i've
experienced that i think we have come a
long way but when it comes to racial
matters and stuff unfortunately i think
we've taken some steps back
i believe all problems are downstream of
economics
and i think when trump says we're gonna
do opportunity zones we're gonna
invest billions and billions of dollars
into low-income areas like in detroit
the gentrification that happened which
i'm a big supporter of
it gave specific family members in my
family
jobs that paid like four times what they
were making before
and that's because a billionaire now
owns like one-third of downtown detroit
like
people complain about it but before i
bet one-third of these buildings
were abandoned that's done more for the
black community than
any president i've known in my lifetime
i feel the tense in that
army feels um but i do feel like
president trump's the leader to lead us
out of that because i see the democrat
party
they see the pain they use it
people who are hurting make them hurt a
little bit more
and and become victims to whatever hurt
they have whether it's racial or
otherwise and and i don't i don't
appreciate that and i don't think that
that's the answer i think
president trump's optimism is the answer
to healing that i really do
i do think that the economy is the
biggest thing and probably the only
thing that president trump
can do for us when it comes to racial
relations i don't personally think that
trump is the answer to race relations
because it's a bigger discussion it's
beyond trump
the best thing that president trump can
do for black america and people of color
is to just give them the opportunity to
thrive and i think he's done that
a great job at that especially you know
before the china virus
took place in everything um but when it
comes to race relations the media has
such a massive part to play
and i think a first step that we could
do as society is
hold our mainstream media accountable if
we
didn't have to dig to see that trump has
denounced white supremacy multiple times
and the mainstream was doing their jobs
and not adding fuel to the fire
um i think maybe as a society we could
all come together
and and hold the media accountable for
the attention that they have caused when
it comes to race relations i don't think
it has anything to do with trump
america has always had you know
political polarization we've always had
racial issues
but at least we have these problems and
we have a robust economy
you know in january and february march
once donald trump gives a second
inaugural address
we'll see the economy bounce right back
he's not the president
in order to gain power when covet
happened
he did not use the opportunity to assert
more power than he already had
it really concerns me when politicians
like joe biden say
he's going to make the entire country
follow a mandatory mass
mandate that's completely unacceptable
it's an overreach of power
i think a lot of why america is so
strong is because we have
such a strong leader like president
trump and he cares he genuinely cares
about america he loves america so much
and he also loves the american people
so i think it's like super nice to just
see that
um a president who is enthusiastic
to work for this beautiful country that
i love and the american people which is
like you and me
so on that note you guys that is a wrap
hey great job everyone all right bye-bye
see you
[Music]
you